so i want to talk about anti-learning
now when it's so bad it's good again
something's so bad it's good i like it
yeah so
you'll have to you'll have to indulge me
for a few minutes to get around to this
but you'll like it in the end
so it's something we've come across when
we were doing a data mining problem to
do with
colon cancer in a machine learning video
i already mentioned briefly about we're
working with clinicians and we want to
solve this problem where
patients are roughly in four groups one
group they're quite healthy they haven't
really got serious cancer one group the
cancer is very serious and then there's
this big group in the middle where we're
trying to say
how serious is it and then the question
becomes should i get radiotherapy you
should take chemotherapy and if you
overdo the therapy you cause more
problems than good and
it's really quite important to split
them but it's very difficult to split
the middle group
so we were given this data set of about
500 patients and
for quite some time we were working on
this data set and we were working hard
and you know
you know maybe we make mistakes
sometimes we're good researchers and
and it seemed a good date i said 500
data 500 people is quite a good quality
quality of data
but we couldn't learn the difference
between the categories in the middle it
really was difficult for us to do that
and we tried all sorts of methods we
started with supervised methods
because they're better usually and they
didn't really work very well and then we
went to some unsupervised methods and
that didn't really make any sense in the
data either and we could do the
easy the hard groups we could do but we
couldn't do the middle group and we
tried for about two years
i'm not joking i was really thinking
we're just tearing hair out
is the data just rubbish or what's going
on we couldn't understand it
and then it's one of those things that
happens in universities one summer
i somehow agreed to supervise this
medical student on a master's project i
don't know why i agreed to this and he
came across sometimes to our office to
have a chat and
and he was just he was just doodling
some pictures and he was also
peripherally working on the same data
not exactly but he was doing something
related to this data
and he was drawing these pictures i'll
just draw you a few of these pictures
just to illustrate my point here
so a lot of the data comes kind of in
ordinal values like one two three
four the raw data obviously looks very
messy but then the medics have done
something to it and they just said
one two three four like levels so he was
drawing some of this data and let's say
this could be a particular
value of an immune component in your
body and like one of them you might be
drawing like this and we're like yeah
well okay that's
that's what i expect you know it's one
two three four and the higher number
means you've got more of x whatever x is
immunoglobulin x fine okay make sense
understand
okay and then he was doodling some more
pictures and he was doodling pictures
like this
and it's basically one two three four
okay slightly less obvious but i mean i
still understand okay okay
so he was kind of saying yeah what this
means is you have
four means you have less of x okay and
i don't know why they do it this way
right medics are obviously logical you
know fine
higher numbers less of it i can kind of
buy that should start zero shouldn't it
yeah that's uh but let's not go there
you know i probably don't get that
okay but then and this is where it got
really really interesting he was
doodling some more pictures
he was doing one like this
and i was like what's this one two three
four and it like goes up and down
and he was like yeah because when you
have a lot of this eggs or a little of
this eggs then you're really quite ill
and it's when you have the middle amount
of x then you're right then you're
healthy this is a good level of
x great so it's a good good x versus not
so good x and high and low is not so
good
and then obviously the last one he was
drawing was it looked a bit like this
where suddenly it was like well you know
when you have a medium amount of feet
that's when there's something wrong with
you you either have not a lot of it or
you have a lot of it then you're healthy
oh this this medicine is complicated
isn't it so we're suddenly starting to
realize we've got this this data 500
patients and for each patient we had
about two or three hundred of these
observations
and it wasn't salted like i imagined
where one is small and four is large but
well sometimes one was small sometimes
four was large sometimes
one was large and four was small i can
cope with that but then sometimes it was
also like
the middle ones were good or the middle
ones were bad or it was like all over
the place completely messy
that shouldn't be a problem for the
computer you would think we can
obviously learn all these things
but the complication then came there is
200 of them and they all work together
so what he was basically saying was well
and this one is low and this one is high
that's good
oh and this one is medium and this one
is low that's bad
so so different numbers and different
combinations meant different things
and when he was talking about this i
suddenly clicked something
now let's switch topics for a moment
something you might have heard in
another video about the
exclusive or problem xor so what's the
xor problem
go on i'm testing you now okay if uh if
the inputs differ then you
uh you get a one and if they're the same
then you get a zero that's right exactly
so
we have two inputs keep it really simple
two binary input zero
zero one zero one and basically if
they're the same that's not good we
don't want that
but if they're different yeah you get
your reward and this is a classic
computer science problem of course
can be programmed in many ways and it
turns out this is also a classic
computer science problem that's really
difficult for computers to learn
and i i'll just give you a simple simple
illustration why that is
so just draw that again what we just
drawn slightly differently
so we have our two variables zero one
zero one so we were saying if they're
the same value
then they're not good so this would be
one one or this would be zero zero
and this would be the two good values so
it would kind of look like this
now basically and i'm simplifying a
little bit now but basically
all this machine learning is actually
learning a function that can separate
the data
into two groups or more than two groups
but let's say two groups for now
and a function at the end of the day
again keeping it simple means you can
draw a line through this that separates
the two groups
now gone then draw me a line through
this that separates
the ticks from the x's
let's have a look okay i think the lines
it's going to be a wavy line isn't it
you can't draw a straight line that
separates those there is no straight
line you can draw is there you would
have to be
like this or something
yeah basically it's not a line anymore
is it it's not a curve of some sort yeah
absolutely
this is it so there is obviously a way
we can separate it with something
complicated
but there's no simple way of separating
them anymore and that's exactly what a
computer finds when it's trying to learn
this and that's just for one zero one
thing
now imagine and this goes back to our
patients now you've got 200 of them
and they'll go between one and four not
just zero and one and some combinations
are good some combinations are bad and
sometimes it goes up and sometimes it
goes down
you have a 200 dimensional mess like
this basically it's just
impossible to learn a function anymore
that kind of separates the things
now once we realized this we had those
sort of brilliant ideas like
okay so it's really easy to get this
problem wrong because obviously i can i
can i can learn the line
and it gives me the wrong answer that's
easy so how about this then
i just learned the wrong answer and i
know now it's wrong because it's the xor
problem
and then after i've learned the wrong
answer which is easy to learn
and then just reverse it
and we called it anti-learning so we
tried this in our big data set
and it worked surprisingly well i mean
before we were getting basically answers
which are 45 percent correct and you
only have two
two choices so it was basically worse
than random and navigating answers
you're 78
correct so it definitely helped so so
bad
it was good and all because of the xor
problem
so what have i done i've done a sorting
of the data and the approach i've done
is something based on similarity
measures
these unsupervised methods they always
use the similarity measure in this case
i've done
kind of by color what i need to exclude
and i'm excluding what i know about
and how to drive and eating and drinking
what i have for lunch and
all my memories about the last you know
34 years of my life
everything maybe a solution might look
like